nuevo tropiezo para el presidente pedro
castillo la fiscalía general de perú
inició otra investigación en su contra
por presunto delito contra la
tranquilidad pública en la modalidad de
organización criminal esta nueva
investigación también involucra a su ex
ministro de vivienda general alvarado y
a su cuñada jennifer paredes quienes
habrían organizado una estructura
criminal para favorecer a empresas
fachadas amigas del presidente en la
licitación de millonarios contratos para
obras de infraestructura
jennifer paredes se entregó a la
justicia mientras que el castillo afirma
que se trata de una persecución política
por parte del congreso la fiscalía y la
prensa
queridos compatriotas
tienen a través de esa agenda mediática
en the session mediático concluidos
con sectores que nunca han hecho nada
por el perú quieren doblegarnos
este es el sexto proceso que se abre en
contra del castillo desde que asumió su
agitado mandato hace un año el delito
contra la tranquilidad pública podría
implicar una detención preventiva de
mínimo tres años sin embargo los
abogados del mandatario argumentan que
la inmunidad presidencial se impide que
pedro castillo vaya a la cárcel hasta
2026 cuando acabe el periodo por el que
fue elegido en las urnas a la crisis
política que vive el país se suma la
tensión entre el legislativo y el
ejecutivo ahora está echando la culpa a
poder ponerse a la fiscalidad a la
prensa al al poder legislativo o sea
todos son culpables de lo de los
supuestos delitos que comete en el
congreso de perú avanza un proceso de
acusación a pedro castillo por traición
a la patria debido a pasadas
declaraciones sobre ceder territorio
peruano a bolivia para tener acceso al
mar de ser hallado responsable tendría
que abandonar la casa